we are in the tokida bathroom
um in Northern California near San
Francisco on Stanford campus something
that was discovered between my son who's
just turned four but he was two at the
time and me two summersible we used to
go to a swimming pool and he really
liked it I would of course cuddle him
and go into the pool and he was very
very happy about the cold water and warm
sun and so on and we took a little ball
with us and we played with this
but then the following experiment was
suggested by my son he wanted me to push
the ball with floating water into the
water and then release and of course it
Bobs up downstairs and stays on surfaced
water and then he said well release
deeper and when I release a little
deeper it pops up
clear above the water it actually jumps
into the air
yeah yeah
and so we thought well if I go deeper
and deeper it will jump higher and
higher but watch what happens when I
release really deep
it just wobbles up to the surface
and you know stays there it doesn't
clear the surface so if you think of the
height to which it pops as a function of
depending on how deep you release it's
not monotonic it's not that you know the
shallower the higher or deeper the
higher actually there is a maximum
around what you might call The Sweet
Spot or sweet interval if a good
distance below the surface where group
it pops rather nicely there has been
some literature on this I discovered
this subsequently and people seem to
talk about pop-up and popping which I
have been doing but I'd like to
introduce a new terminology I think that
it should be called poor posing as in
the animal purpose because you know
those sea creatures purposes dolphins
and seals are able to LEAP out of the
water right and of course these
creatures have very good muscles and
hydrodynamic shapes and so forth but it
would be rather surprising if they
didn't take advantage of this mechanism
where for free just by starting from a
sweet depth
you can leap into the air free of charge
right just by by that so it would be a
good thing that purposes are doing so
that's why it should be called purposing
and besides then we can ask questions
like what's the purpose of purposing and
so on so I'd like to make a suggestion
as to what's going on and which you know
my son mother said the same thing in his
babbling language and so when you dip
very very slowly of course there isn't
really much you know buoyancy and and
there isn't much time or distance of
vegetable and she acts in a floating
force act so I mean it doesn't go very
far and that's understandable and that's
intuitive for everyone else when you
sync them a little deeper then the
buoyancy as I said the floating Force
has sufficient timer and sufficient
distance overall Stacks so it pulls it
up and then you know there is enough
momentum where as it breaches the
surface of the water to go up so that's
again believable you know details can be
calculated by classical
but the Mysteries why if you give it a
really deep release
um it doesn't pop up and I think the
answer is already suggested by what
you're seeing when I release from there
do you see it doesn't go straight up
actually
move sideways it oscillates sideways and
it's you know wasting a lot of energy
and not emotion and when it comes to the
surface that's where it stops yeah so it
goes sideways yeah and that wasn't
really convincing but yeah
so I'm going to let the water settle
yeah yeah it kind of has a has a yeah
sideways motion okay
so at this stage I'm going to
take up the brown paper so this ping
pong ball is moving
forward like that okay now as it moves
forward it has to get the water around
it out of the way so what's going to
happen for example here is a little blob
water
and then this water has to get around
the bowl so it rolls rolls rolls like
that and then comes off so the result is
that it shares what is called a spinning
pattern of water which is called a
Vortex it's just behind like this and
then a little earlier
you are setting some vertex like that
and we would expect that and so on and
so on as it goes up it starts sharing
vertices it's creating some kind of
vertical pattern spinning pattern around
it on this side and on this side in
opposite ways and of course the picture
is three dimensions so it's shedding
vertices all around and so forth now
this kind of sort of spinning pattern
destabilizes the ball and so when it
shares the vortex like this it kind of
pulls this sideways and when it shift
voltage from this side sideways and so
on and it has been noticed that for some
range of motion a speed size and density
of the water and especially viscosity
this shedding is in alternating patterns
so one side the other side one side so
it starts oscillating whereas if you
start from too shallow then this
mechanism doesn't have time to kick in
so it just goes straight up and then
that's very very effective because it
comes straight up and you pop straight
up and purpose excuse me straight up
whereas here if you start too deep you
go sideways and then by the time you
breach you you reach yourself to water
you don't really get there so that's
what's um what's going on Professor I
imagine millions of these are happening
per second though why aren't they sort
of all canceling each other out and
allowing the bowl that is that is a very
good question but the reason is as I
said for this range of motion you know
if it's very very fast or very very slow
that's a different story but for this
kind of daily motion of that size and
magnitude and this shedding it turns out
happens in alternating fashion so you
know there is no cancellation but
because when it's shedding being being
shed over here the previous Vortex is
already far away and the previous one
before that is even further and so forth
so you go one side the other side one
side the other side and that's why
[Music]
if everything was happening much much
faster than everything and then you get
something called turbulence this is a
huge mess of vortices that are kind of
clouds together and so forth then you
know all bets are often do you just get
the messy motion and Professor why does
this mechanism stop the ball from
leaping high is it because it's it's
wasted its energy that's so so it's
wasting a lot of energy behind and we
shall come back to that but also you
know because it goes sideways that's you
know part of the energy that should be
moved um used to move upward and being
wasted sideways and so it doesn't really
have anything left by the time it
reaches the reach the surface okay this
is zero above water and it had some
strange maximum and then goes down so
the question was what is this maximum
well we understood that in fact what was
going on is that somewhere here and some
are here the motion of the
movement of the wall was very different
so here you just you know bobbed up and
down here it kind of went
hidden leader and wasted it much on
Sideways and so it didn't go but here it
cleared the water very nicely by the way
another thing that we didn't really
emphasize when we saw it is that in this
case because it's kind of going sideways
it also tends to Splash quite a lot of
water and that's more wastage if you
like in the in the motion but anyway so
because of this there is some kind of
strange maximum I would say that here
when there is this separation between
this region and this regime is about one
diameter deep when you release and here
when there is some loss that starts
because of this cell Cedar to emotion
ultimately because of the vortex
shedding as we explained is maybe two or
three diameters deep yeah so that's more
or less the picture
I'd like to show you the vortex patterns
that are left behind or in the wake of
the moving wall but in order to see that
best you would like to have a shallower
water so I'm going to let some water out
yeah that's good that's good okay the
vortex pattern that is Left Behind in
the wake of a moving object or the flow
past and then you know in the Wake that
it's formed can be seen in the bathtub
if you have it at the suitable depth so
here you can move a finger across in
your bath or in this case let's move a
familiar
ping pong ball when they move it across
do you see at the bottom of the bath you
see some Shadows of those black spots
lots of black spots on this side on this
side and in some kind of very
alternating pattern it's not so clean of
course but you can see it right and
that's those are the
Shadows of the vortices that are being
left behind and this pattern the
alternative pattern of vortices that are
being shed at all times and which cause
if you like some sideways or station and
so on and and so on will come come back
to that later was discovered by a number
of people but it's now known as Von
Karma Vortex Street and this is really a
very beautiful pattern that
arises behind some fluid motions
in the wake
this pattern is used in rather clever
and in fact the miraculous fashion and
by swimming creatures such as fish
so have you ever wondered why not only
fish but you know seals and dolphins and
porpoises indeed that I mentioned before
have you ever wondered I mean you have
certainly been to see some seal and so
on and you know they don't seem to be
doing anything they just wiggle their
body a little bit and fit off they go
right whereas human Champions the best
of the swimmers have to do so much work
and splash all over the place and then
they don't go that fast do they I mean
you know we can all outrun these people
on the on the ground so how come those
creatures just by wiggling their body go
so fast and so efficiently in terms of
energy and everything that is the
mystery that needs to be explained and
this is how it works to a good
approximation so let's say that the
water is coming from front to back or
this creature is moving from Back to
Front like this like that and let's say
in the first instance that this is a
submarine so it's a rigid body so no
flexibility there there's no animal
mystery there well as I explained well
in the two-dimensional model what
happens is that on this side the water
has to Roll Along the body like this
there is something called No Sleep
boundary condition which was noticed by
stocks in the 19th century anyway so it
rolls and rolls and rolls and then
behind it it leaves Vortex like that on
the other side water rolls and rolls
like this so it's rolling in the
opposite direction and then in the back
it leaves a Vortex like that and so on
it keeps shedding vertices as we say
okay so this is the pattern that is Left
Behind of vortices which we saw some
rough representation of in an experiment
in the bathtub remember this is
completely rich now what's going on you
can see that this Vortex for example is
kind of swirling
um stirring the water around it so it
induces the flow like that around it
which then pushes those things forward
right because it's kind of inducing the
flow like this and on the other side
this Vortex for example is spinning like
that and induces the flow circular flow
like that and it pushes those vertices
forward as well so this row of vertices
and this row of vertices are helping
each other and they're pushing each
other forward that's almost back to
where they came from what they came from
exactly and that's a forward momentum
yeah of this vertex strain Street
but this creature or the submarine then
is leaving a forward momentum in the
wake well that's you know for the
momentum that he really wanted to keep
for itself to keep move forward that he
has wasted by leaving it in the Wake so
that's why it suffers I'm not saying
this is a bad thing because it all left
behind you know this submarine wants to
keep all the four the momentum to itself
but instead it's giving the forward
momentum in the Wake to the fluid that
is leaving behind so you know you are
ejecting this forward moment I'm just
like well I don't want to have any
important technology but anyway so you
know it's all wasted so that's why it
suffers and that's why he feels that
well shorter forward the momentum he
feels as sort of backward Force if you
like and that's called a drag you know
it can't really move forward so easily
that was a rigid submarine which of
course then has to have huge mortars and
so on in order to keep moving forward
and it has to expand a lot of energy now
what does a fish do or one of those
creatures do it does more or less the
same thing because of course the motion
of the fluid is exactly the same water
keeps rotating like this rolling on the
surface of the fish or this swimming
creature like that is the same but a
swimming creature is flexible so it
flexes its body like that yeah and it's
the Flappy motion of the tail and by
doing so it guides this
Vortex on this side and then flicks it
and leaves it on this side and the
vortex that started growing as the fluid
kept rolling on this side again you know
after that it flexes it's still like
that and the flick it leaves on this
side
so it keeps leaving this kind of
vertices on this side and this kind of
vertices on this side
okay
and there
there
and there
he may not be so apparent but this row
used to be over here in the case of
summary and this row used to be over
here in the case of Submarine but what
the fish did by flicking its tail and
placing the vortex on the other side was
to exchange those two rows with respect
to submarine okay with that consequence
well this Vortex again you know induces
circular motion like that and but look
in this case it's pushing the pattern of
what this is backward yeah and this side
is inducing a circular motion and it's
pushing the circular and the partner
voltage is backward in other words those
two rows of vertices
of the vortex Street are actually
helping each other to push backward
that's backward momentum
whereas in the case of a submarine we
had a forward momentum that was left
behind well this creature then uh fish
is leaving backward momentum
in the Wake well that's exactly like a
jet engine you see you're ejecting
something behind which is going that way
very fast by recoil you go forward so it
gains for the momentum yeah because it's
leaving a lot of backward momentum well
that helps and that's how it can go so
fast
because it just exchanged those rows
vertices that is leaving behind thanks
to a judicious
um flexibility of of deflection of its
tail
this episode was brought to you by mail
science creator of these fantastic
subscription boxes full of Hands-On
learning and experiments
appropriately for today's video this
one's called artificial sea everything
you need is in the box instructions are
easy to follow and it's super safe
now I'll be honest I think I mucked up I
may have put a little bit too much
copper sulfate in here
but the result was kind of fascinating
these blue-green bulbous things
constantly growing and then collapsing
and isn't that what experiments are all
about learning investigating maybe
making a few mistakes anyway this is
what it should look like
personally I think a subscription to
these would be a great present for the
Learners in your life there are so many
great boxes and products available check
it all out on the Mel science website
and by the way there's a 60 discount for
the first month of any subscription if
you use the promo code number file 60
the code the link all the details are in
the video description
[Music]
here and now it's hanging here so that's
version number two what's going to
happen if I pull the ends of the paper
well you know somebody not observant
might say oh what's the difference in
here here well probably it doesn't
matter well but you remember that
version number one ended up having the
rubber band hanging from the paper
ribbon